this is a video made by a group of
German physicists the circle in the
background is a kind of mirror that
combined with a special photography
technique allows you to see the flow of
air in this case it is showing how far
air particles travel when someone
breathes and when they cough which makes
the respiratory particles travel further
and faster this is what it looks like
when someone coughs into their hand and
into their elbow and this shows the
travel of air particles when coughing
while wearing two types of masks a dust
mask and a surgical mask this isn't a
scientific study it simply shows
something face masks to do very well
they limit how far away from new
respiratory particles can travel
but whether you've been told to wear a
face mask to prevent the spread of kovat
19 probably depends on where you live in
some East Asian countries it's already
common practice some European countries
have also started mandating face masks
in public spaces but in the US the
message from the federal government has
been inconsistent there's no reason to
be walking around with a mask it's not
providing the perfect protection that
people think that it is CDC recommends
wearing cloth face coverings in public
settings where other social distancing
measures are difficult to maintain this
is voluntary I don't think I'm gonna be
doing it unless you live somewhere that
mandates it whether you wear a face mask
is probably up to you but making that
decision for yourself is a lot easier if
you understand what face masks can
actually do and what they can't here's
where the experts agree if you are sick
and you leave the house you should wear
a face mask because it keeps your germs
in most of the uncertainty around masks
is related to a separate question
whether healthy people should wear them
too right away though that distinction
between sick with kovat 19 and healthy
is more complicated than it sounds
people who catch Cova 19 don't feel
symptoms for five to six days on average
and even up to 14 days but are
contagious before that and based on what
we know right now about 25% of people
who catch it never show symptoms at all
but are also contagious in other words
especially with Cova 19 feeling healthy
doesn't necessarily mean you don't have
it I think we should all be acting and
also all assume that we're infected Shan
solon is an expert on global public
health and Robert Hecht
is a professor of clinical epidemiology
and they say the possibility of being
asymptomatic is one of the best cases
for universal mask-wearing those who are
actually infected and don't know it are
showing almost no symptoms it's not
maybe even primarily for their own
health it's for the health of their
family and neighbors but let's say you
definitely a hundred percent do not have
the virus
the first thing you need to know is that
no masks can actually guarantee you that
you won't get it instead the best way to
think about face masks is as part of a
larger set of protective measures along
with social distancing and hand washing
used together they don't protect you
completely but they dramatically lower
your odds of infection I think of it as
a protective triad with the virus trying
to get in and if you don't have one of
the branches in it and you're not
protecting the whole thing and if you
didn't have a mask could you do better
with social distancing hand-washing sure
but having all freeze it's really really
important to understand how that works
let's look at the two ways Koh v19 is
transmitted one way is by touching an
infected surface and the touch in your
face this is called pho mite
transmission and frequent hand-washing
is the best defense against this but
wearing face masks correctly can play a
role two masks do a really good job of
keeping you from touching your face the
second way someone's respiratory
particles can reach you is directly like
this this is a slowed down recording of
a sneeze it shows the kinds of
respiratory particles that sneeze emits
and how far they travel from a sick
person these droplets are packed with
millions of viral particles that fall in
close range and in fact whatever they
land on social distancing protects us
from droplets by keeping you away from
the particles emitted through sneezing
coughing or even talking but face masks
could help there too so someone who
sneezes a couple feet away from you you
know it'll protect some of the bigger
splashes that also means face masks are
especially important for people who
don't have the privilege of being able
to social distance that would be cops
that would be grocery clerks taxis uber
FedEx and UPS you know anyone who's
coming into contact with a lot of people
and maybe can't always maintain that six
foot distance look at this video again
though and you'll see that we also
produce these longer range smaller
particles which evaporate and can leave
the virus hanging in the air these are
called aerosols and we still don't
really know how infectious they are for
the average person
but experts think they mostly pose a
threat to medical workers who work up
close to patients with Cova night team
if you were a foot away from the patient
who's copying as you're trying to
intubate them aerosols are going
everywhere for you and me you're just
walking around walking your dog or in a
grocery store your risk is is weighed
higher from fomites a common mass that
protects against aerosols is called an
n95 respirator it's name comes from its
materials ability to filter out 95% of
aerosol particles it's also fitted to
form a seal around your mouth and nose
so there's no leakage in lots of places
and 95s are in short supply because of
diminished government stockpiles and
disruptions and the supply chains and
that's true for all disposable masks not
just n95 that's why the u.s. Center for
Disease Control says that unless you are
a healthcare worker you shouldn't be
using either an 95s or regular surgical
masks they are needed in hospitals and
the level of protection most people need
can come from a simple cloth mask the
CDC recommends any kind of tightly woven
cotton for the masks or even a t-shirt
you can make them by consulting the
countless internet tutorials out there
or buy them from the many vendors who
manufacture them but they only work if
you wear them correctly so what kind of
masks are you wearing do you have them
handy can you show us we thought you
might guys this is all it takes to put
it on just grab it by the loops keep
your hands off the the central part put
it over your nose and mouth loop it
around the ears be careful not to touch
it when you're outside keep your hands
away from your face when you come back
in after walking the dog we're doing the
groceries do the same thing in Reverse
put it off to the side don't start
playing with it and then just at the end
of the day pop it in the washer you wash
it every day I wash them every night and
you know even if you don't have a washer
I mean you can hand wash them every
night they're very small and they'll be
tried by the next morning so if people
can have a couple it would be better if
you only have one then just wash it at
night
face masks highlight something important
in the fight against Kovan 19 that it
isn't always about protecting yourself
it's about protecting the people around
you
and if everyone is doing it we all
protect each other there's a visual
messaging that comes from wearing a mask
a reminder about everybody we're not in
normal times now everyone needs to be
doing everything they can to protect
themselves and other people
[Music]
[Music]